buzos escudriñan las aguas de la costa
de La Isla italiana de isla mientras
helicópteros la sobrevuelan el sábado un
deslizamiento arrastró la ladera de una
montaña hacia el puerto de la localidad
de casa michola desde entonces varias
personas siguen desaparecidas la tierra
derrumbó edificios acarreo vehículos y
volteó árboles está residentes se
encontró en su camino
escapamos teníamos esta ola que venía
hacia nosotros Tan rápido tuve un
segundo para salir de su camino si
hubiera tomado dos habría muerto gracias
a Dios estamos vivos
los bomberos dicen que en algunos
lugares el lodo tiene unos seis metros
de profundidad el sábado este hombre
cubierto de barro y aferrado a su puerta
fue salvado por los bomberos las labores
de rescate se vieron obstaculizadas por
la lluvia y Los Fuertes vientos que
también retrasaron que traían ayuda las
autoridades pidieron a los residentes
que permanecieran en sus casas el
desprendimiento fue provocado por las
lluvias más intensas que se han
registrado en la isla en dos décadas los
expertos dijeron que el desastre Se dio
agravado por las construcciones en zonas
de alto riesgo más de 160 personas se
han quedado sin